Tricia's with us in Atlanta Georgia I
treasure how are you hi babe I'm doing
great how are you better than I deserve
what's up what sighs I wanted to thank
you for taking my call and it's great to
speak with you
my mom is anticipating her company
folding or I guess you know going out of
business and she you know anticipating
possibly losing her job and she isn't
currently living on a budget she's
living paycheck to paycheck and she's in
Baltimore and so you know we've had
conversations about her possibly moving
down to Atlanta I'm just getting back on
her feet getting a new job and you know
me helping her through the process and
so I've been telling her about you and
about your videos and all the stuff that
I've been learning I'm currently on baby
steps to you and you know so I'm always
encouraging her to get on a plan and to
just manage her money better and more
wisely and so far you know it's kind of
much been the same excuses you know
living paycheck to paycheck and you know
there's some things that I know that she
can settle but I just don't believe that
she would be willing to sell some things
just to make a little extra money you
know it's a possibly fund the move down
here and so I'm just wondering if
there's if you could tell help me pls
way to approach the situation you know
by possibly offering the help or move
down here funding the move how to go
about that and possibly help her you
know make the first step forward into
being wiser with her money
well your your concern I think I'm
reading between the lines is that you're
giving a drunk a drink that by paying
for this you're enabling her misbehavior
sure it would be fast money fast easy
money and so you know when it's usually
like that people don't really appreciate
or even tablet what I often do is
sometimes I will tie a the offer of help
money help which is what you're offering
to a behavior change that's good for
them and so you know mom I'll be willing
to pay for your move down here but
you're going to have to graduate from
Financial Peace University before I will
okay you have to go to the class nine
weeks there's plenty of them in
Baltimore and I'll pay for that it's
hundred bucks mom and but you got to go
through the class if you'll go through
the class I'll pay for that I'll pay for
the class and I'll pay for your move
okay I'm not just going to pay for your
move because you're pitiful right right
and that's something that our that my
family tends to do you know soon if
somebody needs money we just kind of
like fork it over so yeah I would like
to kind of break that chain know what
just tell her that just say home on you
you know what I want to do is I want to
be a blessing to you and participating
with you financially while you misbehave
financially is like giving a drunk a
drink and I don't want to do that I
don't want to I don't want to help you
do the wrong things I want to help you
do the right things and so I am willing
my husband I've talked about it we're
willing to pay for your move up to you
know $2000 or 3002
if you will go to and Graduate Financial
Peace University starting right now and
we'll get you in the class and I'll pay
for that but it's nine weeks you have to
go once a week for nine weeks you have
to go and you have to attend all nine
times and if you do that then I will
help you at all
if you do not then I think you're going
to continue to misbehave and understand
good money after bad and I don't really
want to do that I don't think that's
good for you mom because I love you too
much okay she will react one of two ways
sometimes when you give people guidance
like that they're angry right and
especially because it's coming from her
daughter telling her to be more in
fossil so no I'm not wagging my finger
in her face I'm just saying
mom I've observed that you're not
winning with money you're broke and and
it's not because you don't make enough
it's because you don't handle what you
have and I'm learning that too and I'm
going to a class and I'm learning to do
that so we've talked about it we're
willing to help you if you will learn
how to handle money and that means you
need to go this class
I'll pay for it but you know and she may
react negatively I mean she may be angry
you owe me I raised you I fed you I
changed your diaper what happens with
mothers a lot of times in a situation
sometimes fathers as they become travel
agents for guilt trips and they just
sign you up for some kind of guilt trip
and you just have to say you know what
this is not about me this is about you
and I want to help you help you help me
help you help you that's what we're
trying to do it's about her we're not
trying to be mean we're trying to be
loving but when you participate in
someone's insanity I mean that's like
you biner a bag of cocaine if she's a
cocaine addict that's not helpful well
my family there's always people money
you always you get my bag of cocaine
when they have trouble you know I mean I
don't care what your that means your
family's stupid it's what that means and
every family's got some of that you know
not your family when talking about you
but I mean people say stuff like that
all the time but you know just because
families have dumb ways of doing things
doesn't mean that you have to do it it's
not like a rule it's just you're on come
on be the first one it's not going to
participate in and um and I'm gonna be
the one breaks a chain here hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]